Oh no!
Wahoo!
Let's go to meet MarsiO!
welcome back to the stream welcome back to the stream welcome to back to the Mario RPG
I'm so sorry I I'm a little late I went to an idol meeting and and there was no
paper there was no paper and then after I found the paper no paper I got I got the
paper after I got the paper I did everything I washed my hands I went out and Mama and
Papa stopped me to talk stop and I was like oh no I'm already late and they're like did
you know about this how's the work is everything okay I was like no no not right now please
I have to go and then and then and then I felt bad but I had to kick them out because they
were being really loud so yeah was Koopa so this is where you went off to this is Smithy's
castle you fucking little traitor is schwot schwot you you you I need an insult give me a second
you you you Santa rip off you you low crusty
elf thing you beady for eyes you little snaggle tooth jaundice creature
ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha
ah stinky
no trespassers allowed
all right you know what to do, right?
Have I tried this before?
Where was the boost attack up?
This one's squirrel.
Wow.
I'm slow.
And then, mawio.
Ah! Oh, that was a lot still.
Last!
Ah!
Beach, get in here!
No! Not an egg!
I hate eggs! Disgusting things!
Okay.
Oh! Okay, not bad, not bad.
Okay, can't block that. Got it.
Okay, okay, group hug! Group hug!
Yes, yes, yes.
Die!
Coward!
I think I like your jaundice four eyes the best.
Hey.
Can do triple move, I think.
Nah, we'll just hit this one first.
Ah! How many eggs do you have?
Yes, stinky eggs.
Is the jinx clone going to hurt?
Is it going to hurt?
Is it as strong as jinx?
Ah! Fuck it.
Oh, thank you. It was not.
Flap! It's what you get!
Only ten!
Lizakupa!
Huh? Where am I? Bowser, hello! How have you been?
I made it back here somehow, but it seems like I've been brainwashed or something.
This seems like an excuse. A likely excuse.
I can't seem to remember everything. Have I done something wrong?
Ugh, don't worry about it. Let's just put it behind us.
It's great running into a loyal minion like you.
I don't, I don't think so. I don't think so.
I'm glad. It looks like you've got some tough new minions now, but my magic can still help you.
Watch this! Hey, what you pay for it?
This magic treasure box will never run out of coins. Just keep hitting it.
I'll be here if you need me. Come by when you need to rejuvenate HP and magic.
You're not lying to me, right?
Is it actually infinite?
Is it really infinite? Not counterfeit?
Oops, hold on. Oops, I didn't mean to do that. I want- Ah! Hold on, buttons!
Party? Yes, you here. Yes, Peach stays.
Maybe Gino instead of Bowser. No, Bowser. For this section.
So, use 10%, get 10% off, game yourself, using cold mercy.
Wow, what a great deal.
Please buy a lot. Use my cold a lot and I too can get a waifu cup.
Like, actually, though? Wait, how much did I get now? Oh, well, whatever.
What's in door one?
What's in door two?
You still hanging around? Oh, you want more items, huh? Since I'm in a good mood, just remember, I can't always be coming to your rescue, you know?
Is anything else you need? Best to buy it now.
Uh, got it. Uh, I will get everything, please.
Is start cape good?
It's got better defense, I guess.
Yeah!
I better go- Wait, bye.
Bye.
Bye. Let's just get everything. Bye.
Anything else?
I'll buy the dress, but I won't equip it. I just think it's cool.
See ya. How? Oh, he's our friend now?
He's our friend now?
We have friend now?
We have friend?
I'm going.
I'm so sad.
You caused me so much trouble, but your little, your little pal thing saved me.
Okay, I'll clear now.
I just want the money.
Can I make it back to a thousand?
Oh yeah, and money for fireworks.
My gosh, that's expensive fireworks.
500 each? That's so wild.
I'm almost there.
Why did I have to jump for this, huh? Can I at least get two?
What the heck is auto-jump?
Yeah, nice even number.
Give me a second.
Just in case.
One, I don't trust myself. Two, I also still don't trust myself.
What's turbo control?
Ah!
Ah, four!
I don't even think I can get to 30. To be honest, I don't think I can get to 30. See?
Oh!
My record was 15.
Ah!
I'm still gonna just hit it.
I'm not very good.
Jump on it!
Well, more practice.
Fuck, I got worse.
Actually, can I switch you out for Gino?
Ooh! Can I do that again?
Not bad.
I gotta make this right!
This is the biggest one I've seen.
Is there anything on top?
Ha ha ha ha!
Ah, so you're the notorious Mario. I'm impressed you made it thus far.
I didn't think you could. Wait, why are the shy guys like holding on to the stuff?
The chandelier.
Oh feisty little fellow, aren't you? But this is the end of the line.
Now you've got to deal with me, on guard!
Do what? His name's Boomer.
Do I hit Boomer? Can I hit the shy guy thing?
Wow, I really do suck.
I suck.
Oh, that's not bad.
Die!
Sorry, I'm trying to practice so much.
Ah, Gino beam!
Thanks, the other attack did more!
Why is he a different color?
Oops.
Argh, this is absurd! I can't be defeated by them!
I won't let this happen! I won't fall in battle!
I'm having an attack!
I don't need your sympathy! I'm a soldier, I'm prepared to go!
Take a dive, shiny chandelier, ouch!
See ya, kids.
Boomer, oh poor Boomer!
I'm not too worried, a little fall isn't going to hurt you.
Alright, Mario, I'll lead you to the top. Must hurry to the pointed place.
Hang on tight! In the way we go!
Boomer's committed sudoku.
You're getting the hang of it! Increasing speed!
Now we're just dancing as he did!
As he committed sudoku!
He's just dancing on his corpse.
Next stop, top four. Please fasten your seat belts in.
Wait a sec, there are no seat belts!
I didn't win that much, damn.
The eyes are protecting X-Saur! Okay, understood.
Um...
Left eye or right eye?
I mean, plastic!
Left, right, left, right.
Man.
Please don't kill me. I'm begging you, please don't kill me. Oh thank goodness.
Wait, X-Saur is this thing on top? Not down here? Wait, the bad guy is here? Not here?
Wait, who's X-Saur? I thought we were fighting Smithy!
Oh no, this isn't the real boss, is it?
Aw man.
X-Saur's protection is gone. Ow!
I think I need Peach here soon.
I think I can triple move this. I'm gonna get it again, right?
Alright, friendship! Let's go! Please do not say one.
I will literally start crying again.
I need...
Aw man.
Oof, oof, oof, I need you to switch with Peach right now.
So pog!
Oof.
Okay, okay, you can do this, Peach.
You can do this. You can do this, Peach, okay?
Oh!
What the fuck was that?!
Wait, I just... wait!
Okay!
But I did max damage? I'm a fucking god.
I'm a fucking god!
Do you know where this leads to? It looks like the X-Saur's the contact between the two worlds. In other words, if we follow this road, we'll find Smithy. What's keeping us?
Hang on! Wait, sorry. Hang on!
Hey, I only joined so I could get my castle back! I'm not going to be dragged along on this stupid hunt!
I'm going to gather my minions and rebuild my castle!
And you, Mario, as an official member of Bowser's minion, is your duty to help with the repairs!
Bowser, you're completely missing the point.
I ought to rip your stuffing out! He's made of wood, Bowser! You can't rip out stuffing out of wood!
No. Wait, no. Think about it, Bowser. X-Saur connects the two worlds, right? Even though we defeated X-Saur, there will be other weapons, beasts, that come through that connection.
The castle is at the entrance point to your world. In short, the weapons will all pass through your castle.
Is that what you want?
Um, well, more weapon things coming to take over my castle. What about my privacy?!
I understand, Bowser. I understand. I, too, have little to no privacy.
Yikes. This isn't good and far. Good at all. In fact, the strings!
But I just can't be pals with these nincompoops. I got an image to keep up.
He cares about his image! It's okay! We're cool! Sort of! Kind of!
Yeah!
I've got it! No one insults Bowser's minions and gets away with it! I've got a bone to pick with the smithy guy!
Come on, Mario! Let's teach him a lesson right now, together!
I'm so sly!
It looks like we're together on this one. Let's go.
He's so soon!
What's this do?
Wait! I can just fucking leave?! I can just fucking leave?!
That's so funny that I can just fucking leave.
Oh, this animation's kind of cute, though.
Do we have everything we need, those senpai?
Actually, let's go back.
There's only one thing I need, and I need, um...
Coolix? I think I'm not strong enough for Coolix.
Frog coin and fourium, hold on.
I got a lot of these.
Oh, it's a panel card holder! What can I get you?
All members fully heal.
Where can I get more FP stuff?
Where can I get more FP stuff? You know, to heal my FP.
Like, I want to heal all of my FP, maybe here?
So, whatever you're... hold on, hold on. Let me look.
I want this one, Royal Syrup!
I want more of that!
Is this just not a thing I can get?
I can't buy Royal Syrup, but I want it!
And that's fine.
Oh, that sucks.
Well, that sucks. I've got enough stuff. Okay.
Hold up, let me save first.
Hold on, let me save first, so I can...
Do you have any red essence?
Oops, not that one, hold on.
No. What is that?
Where can I get this red essence?
Is it blood? Is it the blood of my enemies?
Well, okay, we have a choice, Empire.
Do I fucking die and fight that Final Fantasy-esque character?
Or do I fight the main boss and finish the game?
Everyone, I see a few people... majority of people do the Final Fantasy guy.
Okay, we'll do the Final Fantasy guy.
What's the Final Fantasy guy again?
Yeah, here.
Also, if I jinx if you haven't done the rematches, I haven't.
Okay.
I'm gonna suffer.
My jinx is up there.
Time to show the power of polygons and things and stuff.
You wish to challenge me? Yeah.
Alright, you asked for it. No crying if you get hurt.
I'll cry only a little bit.
This is where all things don't work.
Dang it.
Oh, well, I'm pretty strong enough.
Think I can jump on him?
No, he's too small.
No! He barely took any damage! It only works on Exor, cries.
Oh, I can do a group hug again.
Bino beam!
Ah, you missed! Okay, we can do this.
Ow, I'm so slow with blocking.
Oh, I beat my record!
I beat my record just by a tiny little bit.
Just by your, like, one!
Oops.
Sorry, I'm still trying to get 30. Ah, shit!
Heal is simply amazing. We did it.
Still haven't had enough? It isn't often I have someone this competitive to spar with.
Alright, since this match will be the one that counts, since I'm placing my reputation online.
Okay, give me one.
Give me a second. Can I heal here?
No. Where'd I heal? Here?
Oh wait, does he give me my heals back? I can't remember.
Oh yeah, I'm already healed.
Oh yeah.
Okay, let's do it again. Yeah.
Watch closely. Jagger, you're about to see your sensei in action.
Ah, I missed! I'm such a fool.
Okay, that missed.
Sorry. I'm going to try this.
Oh, I suck.
I'm just going to stick to this.
Ah, I'm getting worse!
Okay.
Oh, I'm getting worse. Okay, come back!
Wee!
Missed. Ow. That was not good.
Now my hands are like not working.
I'll kiss. I'll kiss. I'll kiss.
Fuck! I want to get past 10 at that time.
Okay, um, karaoke.
Bowser?
Oh, resistance. Nice.
I was so good at it before.
What happened to me? What happened to me?
Hold on.
I was doing so well, and now I'm a failure.
What happened? What happened?
Okay.
Guys, do that.
Wee!
Barely does anything.
Okay, one more time.
Never mind. You're simply amazing.
Well, you're a stronger champion, no doubt about it.
My reputation was staked in this last fight, so I've lost a title of sensei.
From now on, you are the sensei of this dojo.
You take this belt, which only the highest ranking fighter in the dojo can wear.
You got a jinx belt.
You will rename the dojo, Mario style dojo, and incorporate your jump technique into the training.
Wait!
Wait, wait, wait, no!
Jager and I will start our training immediately.
1,000 warm-up jumps begin. Ready? Begin.
Mario sensei, the new gym, and we'll strengthen us, right?
Master, share your wisdom with us.
Wait, wait, I didn't want to be... He changed the sign!
Did he, like...
Did he add, like, a little thing?
The M looks so weird.
Did he add a cliff hit?
Ghost middle.
Emblem of power.
Look at that!
Nice.
Let's go save.
I can't see the stats, but I bet they're good.
Um, hold on.
No, not that.
Can you see it now?
Trying my best. There we go.
Yeah.
Big numbers.
Attack merge!
Give me a second then.
There, look at the attack!
There.
Big numbers.
I'm gonna put it back though.
Wait, wait, wait. No, no, no, no, no.
Can I already save?
Um, next up...
It's this guy, right?
We got everything, I think we're ready.
Let's go.
Greetings.
Wait, did I meet him before?
I thought I already met him before, am I?
I'll just do it again, I'll just do it again.
I am Kulix, Dark Knight of Vanda.
I have crossed into this dimension to fight the Dark Mage.
Who, you, who stand before me, where does your death come from?
Why are you surrendered so three-dimensionally?
The evil power that gave me life mapped out this flat plain as my form.
You were four from a power unknown to me.
I wish to gain the secret of your three-dimensional world.
Will you enter combat against me?
Unguard!
I am matter.
I am antimatter.
I can see your past.
I can see your future.
I consume time.
And I will consume you.
I think we gotta get rid of these crystals first, right?
Oh!
What?
Oh, okay, we're doing good.
Okay, where were we fine?
Before this, this, okay, maybe we're not doing as fine.
That was a lot of stuff, but don't worry, we got this, probably.
Okay.
Are you fucking kidding me right now?
Sorry, not that, I can, I just, something, just give me a second.
Give me a second, okay?
Sorry, I'll thank you for the five gifted.
No, no, no, not that, not that, sorry, I can, just something, just something.
Give me a second.
Okay.
I'm so sorry about that.
Everything should be okay, I think.
Should I buy this Mecha Koopa Stomp?
Oh shit, I missed that.
Peach is doing just fine.
Bowser, not as much.
Did I super jump on this Wind Crystal?
Oh, it worked, sort of.
Okay, everyone just live, please.
Good luck.
There you go.
Hey.
Peach is like tanking everything.
Good luck.
I can't believe Peach is tanking everything so perfectly.
Although me, I'm not doing anything perfectly right now.
I'm getting worse.
I'm gonna try switching.
Let's try Gino Flash.
And it's on!
Okay, that worked.
I need more of that.
Yeah, Maple Syrup.
Oh.
Oh, that's kind of hard.
Come on, come back.
There we go.
Oh, not fireball, super jump.
Earth, water, which one next?
Crystal, fire crystal, water crystal.
Water next?
Fuck you, water.
Okay, that's it for this video.
Thanks for watching.
For Peach.
There we go.
Oh, yeah.
Okay, well, please come back.
Gino?
I have an item to heal everyone.
Oh.
Can we mellow?
Okay, let's have ourselves another Maple Syrup.
Oh, I got a freebie, nice.
Ow.
Earth crystal.
Earth crystal or fire crystal?
Do earth crystal.
There's, what happened to the animation?
Fuck!
Shit. Shit.
Get in here, Bowser. Take Bowser.
Fuck this fire crystal.
How can this earth crystal be using water moves? I don't get it.
I don't get it.
I don't get this bitch back.
I keep on failing.
Oh, I blocked it. Yay!
Ah, you little shit.
Does the earth crystal? I don't know.
Probably not, huh?
Triple move.
No. That's... nah.
Okay, here we go.
He's just, like, carrying so hard.
I think everything's good.
Thank goodness.
Now we just have to slap this bitch.
Does this work on you?
No.
Just the man's left!
Well, I should probably group hug.
Shit.
Shell him.
Slap.
Oh my gosh, Peach.
Peach!
Peach! You're the MVP right now!
Ow.
Did we do it?
Woohoo!
Oh my gosh, look, we leveled up some!
Should we do more physical?
Should we do more physical or more magic?
Magic? Okay.
All Bowser leveled up, too.
Magic?
Physical?
Bowser does pretty strong.
Okay, well, Bowser can get physical.
Ah, your spirit is strong.
This legendary strength is the power of that third dimension.
It is far mightier than the forces of malevolence could dream.
I will treasure this memento of my journey here.
Perhaps in another time, I will be able to do more physical.
I will be able to do more physical.
Perhaps in another time, another game, we may have been mortal enemies.
Someday I will gain the power of this third dimension,
and those forces will visit a land not yet mapped until that time.
Take this.
Treasure it as a keepsake of our fight.
Got a quartz charm.
Farewell, champion knight.
Goodbye, Tootie.
Well, I wonder what the piranha plant says now.
Your neighbor moved away.
Yeah.
Now I need to restock.
You have maple syrup? Yeah, you have tons of maple syrup.
Thank you, Enos, for this two super chat.
Mercy, do you plan on playing the Pulse game?
There's a Pulse game?
Oh, I gotta equip it, right.
Put it on.
Pino?
What does it do?
Force of shining power.
Oh, it's too weak.
Look, it's all red.
It just do anything.
Everything goes down.
The charm doesn't show the stat boosts it gives, but it's the most powerful item.
The hidden buff?
Well, who'd I give it to?
I guess I'll give it to Bowser then.
Here you go, Bowser.
Mario already has the jinx thing.
Okay.
Anything else we need? No, we're all good.
Okay, let's go fight the big bad now.
I'm so strong.
I'm such a player.
I'm such a god.
I beat 2D, and now I gotta beat 3D.
Alright, let's go.
This animation is so cute.
Where's the 3D when? Oh, I want a 3D model so badly.
But, um...
This is the part that's the hardest.
This is the hardest part.
No!
Please.
Okay.
This is the hardest part.
Senpai!
Thank you, Misaka best for $1.99.
Super Cat, platforming my beloved.
And thank you for the $2.00, Super Cat, you know cheap.
Best of luck, Mercy, with Endgame also platforming.
Thank you.
Why is platforming so hard?
Senpai!
Mario, don't you fucking dare.
Thank you.
Senpai!
Thank you, Anonymous, for the $6.90 tip.
Good luck with the platforming, Kohai.
Thank you.
And thank you for the $5.00, Super...
Griffin, I was gonna say Mercy.
The one enemy, Mercy, has the hard time with platforming.
It's true.
Yeah!
Yeah, this is the best.
Yeah, I did it.
Yeah, first try, nobody saw the rest, right?
Nobody saw the other.
Please don't do this again.
I don't wanna do it again.
No!
Hippopol?
No.
There's probably a super attack coming that I will need this for.
Alright, Gino Flash, let's go.
You know you're a gamer when your hands just are all super sweaty?
Oh!
Get hit!
Get hit, get hit!
Why is this thing so stinking strong?
There we go.
Special enemies sometimes feel like they're stronger than, you know, regular.
Okay, you, you get magic because that's all you're good for.
And Gino, you also get magic because that's also what you're good for.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Nobody did that.
Nobody noticed that.
Oh, that's nice.
Oh, man.
Oh, no.
Which way do I go?
Oh, dui dui dui dui dui duii duii duii dui duii duii duii duii duii duii.
Prepare to die.
Oh, man.
Therapy Mario, Wahoo, oops, not close enough, YAY!
Wow, I am so bad, oh well.
Oh!
Great Azura Raid!
Mario!
Bye Azura, bye Azura, welcome Azura, welcome Raiders!
It's me, Mercio, Mercio.
It's me, Wahoo!
How was this dream?
How was, did you do well in the club?
No, I'm not the Mercy, today I'm a Mercio.
Lamao was very chaotic but super fun.
I'm glad, I'm glad, I saw a little bit of it and I saw everyone fall and I thought it was great.
Just like how I'm gonna fall.
Now, welcome everyone, welcome in, as you can see we are playing Mario RPG.
No, give me a second.
I meant, I meant, we are playing a Mercio RPG!
Okay, peachy, peachy, it's magic.
Excuse me.
Yeah!
I hate this, I hate platforming, platforming is my enemy.
A pizza, pasta, a pizza, pizza, pasta, put it in a box, bring it here and put it on my...
Fuck.
I'm going so slowly because I'm bad at this.
Yeah!
Is there anything over there?
Oh no, good.
I don't have to go that way.
What's this one?
What's this one over here?
Ah.
There's so many little guys, I'm able to push the button.
There's so many little guys.
Can I kill them all?
Can I kill all the little guys?
Die!
It's okay.
Understandable, have a nice day.
I wasn't familiar with your game, little guys.
Okay.
Oh, you got Ultra Hammer.
What's this over here?
Okay.
That was so mean.
This is so...
I've been wiping enemies left and right.
I was him until I was...
I wasn't...
I'm...
Shit.
It's a little nudge.
There we go.
It's tiniest.
Tiniest.
Okay.
Which way is it, Senpai?
Ah!
I'm not going to cry.
I'm not crying.
You're crying.
Okay.
That was so mean.
Yes!
Okay.
Fucking get hide.
It's a clock, it's Mario, it's Mario.
How did he get here?
He better do something.
Do I kill the ding-a-lings first or a ding-a-ding?
You know, flash!
Oh!
Whee!
Ah!
Not this move again.
One o'clock is time for ice storm!
I think we'll be okay.
I can do this again.
Peach is so strong now.
I'm so proud of Peach.
I can't block all good.
Ah!
Not the spores!
There we go.
Five o'clock, time to view the aurora!
Man.
Aw, man.
Get out of here, Bowser.
Good, one of them is dead.
Six o'clock, time to fully recover!
No way!
It's almost dead already!
Let's do a reverb.
Ten o'clock, time to draw a bath!
Aw, man.
Sorry, gotta drink, gotta drink.
Get the fuck out of here.
Ten o'clock, guess I'll break!
Ten o'clock, time to garden!
Group hug!
Come on!
Ten o'clock, it's high noon!
Luckily I faced this attack so many times already.
Fuck!
Come on, group hug!
Aw, thank goodness, it's over.
It's over!
This clock is stronger than I expected!
I didn't like it.
Aw, thank you for the save, point.
I have money!
Wee! Fuck!
Money? What's this tiny little path?
Wee!
What?
Ah!
Where did it make me go?
Huh?
Oh, that's nice.
Oh, thank you.
Where am I supposed to go, though?
Aw, fuck.
Aw, not these fake little guys again!
Oh, well, it's not bad.
Could be worse.
We are really doing okay, actually.
Fuck.
We're doing okay!
Aw, no.
Oops.
Just time to massacre all of them.
Aw, man, not again.
Goodbye.
Goodbye, you little shit.
They're so weakly.
Are these all the, like, fake bosses and stuff?
Oh, my gosh, it is the fake bosses.
Oh, hey, I'm pretty good at this, huh?
Okay, we're good.
Okay, let's do it. Where's the Yoshi?
Yeah! I still got it!
Oh, yeah.
I'm not doing much.
Alright, they're dead.
I forgot, they're dead. Therefore, where is it?
There we go.
Okay.
It's been in the middle again, right, guys?
Oh, yeah.
What's this way?
Am I allowed to see?
Wait.
Oh, there's a box here. Don't want it.
Max mushroom, nice.
Well, over here.
There's stuff over there, too.
Come on.
I'm greedy.
Ah!
I was too greedy.
Oh, unofficial harem raid, what happened?
Hello, everyone!
How are you?
Wait, what happened? Why is it unofficial?
But welcome, everyone!
Welcome to the stream!
Excuse me.
Oh, sorry. I mean, welcome to the stream!
It's me, Murcio!
She was so tired, she forgot to raid.
Okay, fair, fair, fair, fair, fair.
Oh, thank you, thank you.
Thank you for the unofficial raid, my sister Shibi.
Y'all know who I am, so that's okay.
Can I bitch slap a ghost? Yes.
What is it?
Oh, that was a really strong move! Yay!
Yay!
Bowser, you got the stuff! Let's get physical! Yeah!
Yeah.
Oh, wait, no, I didn't mean it. I didn't mean that.
Ah!
Oh, we're good. Fuck, yeah.
Oh, I didn't see that. Yeah, box!
Oh, syrup! Yay, syrup! Fuck!
Ha ha ha ha!
Okay, Peach, you tried your best, but that's okay.
You're not here to hit. You're here.
Oh, I blocked it! Yeah, fuck yeah!
I'm a god of gaming!
Wee!
Ow.
Okay, Peach, I need your help later. Thanks.
Can we get a group hug? Yeah, let's do a group hug.
Aha!
I blocked it!
I'm so proud of myself.
Ooh, Mario leveled up again!
Physical?
Magic. Ah, it's physical. Yeah, that was a good one.
Oh, Malo too!
Magic!
Ha ha ha!
Wait, where did I run?
Wait, did I run backwards?
Yeah, I went backwards.
Wait, I won it all that way, and then I forgot everything, and I'm so stupid.
I'm so stupid. It was the other way.
Hmm, what?
Ah!
That was my bad
That was uh, yeah, that was uh
Oopsies, that was oh, yeah, that was me
I think I got like a flower thing in a while already got this that was my bad
Oh
Okay, we're good. We're good good gaming
Okay ghost nobody cares about ghosts
Come on Bowser. You can beat up a ghost. I know you can beat up a ghost. Everyone can beat up ghosts
Ah
They are really good at hp stuff though. I'm not hp leveling up. Oh these good
They're pretty good at leveling up
Oh shit
I'm missing them
There you go
Exp grind
It's okay. We're almost there. I think we're almost there
Can't use x. Okay, that's fine never needed x anyways
Oh
Goodbye forever
What is this I have to fight all of them
Oh
All right
Group hug
There we go
Oh
I didn't even hit anyone yet
There we go
Ah, I ain't close enough. I always get the first move
Oh
Unfair really
Mario wake the fuck up
Oh
Oh, we're good
We got another royal syrup that's good
Ah
I don't I don't know if I can
Oh
Bowser can technically heal up like that, but I'm gonna do a group hug anyways
Yeah for good
You put syrup in the box. This is just an item grind now
I'm still
Still kind of bad
Oh
What happened to all the exclamation marks
What happened to the exclamation marks for how I time things
I miss it
Oh
I
Missed my exclamation mark and helped me so much. I need my visual cues
I think I'm good, but I'm actually a lie
And another one
Oh
No a only why that's fine
Let's get my practice in
That was not much practice in
Oh
There we go
Didn't do much though
Oh
There's it
Keep the syrup look at a freebie
Oh
There you go
Yeah
We did it we did it I got things and stuff get over here. Yeah
Save yeah
Is this the boss time
No
Hey items but also where is it
Where's the exit I don't want to fight this I don't buy I don't want to fight this guy
Hey, where's the exit?
Do I have to fight him?
What's going on here?
Oh
There's a hole this hole do I fall on this hole?
Which hole
Hmm this hole
Maybe I do have to beat him and then it'll hop it'll open the hole
Oh, it's easier than I thought
Oh
Is this wait who the hell are these guys wait behold they've taken the bait
I guess I can spare a few minutes. Maybe they'd like to play
Hey
Who the fuck are you?
Fuck it
Oh, they they're still alive. Okay sure
Okay, I got this
Goodbye
This this tougher than I thought I don't like where this going
What you do suck
If I hit him bad adder
How fucking snake if I hit this thing or him
I
Take down the pilot
Oh that one's kind of strong
Oh, okay
Oh
Everybody get their help off
That's a poison poison kill of coos call
Oh
Okay, he just dies too. Okay. Well only 40 seriously
I
Was over here then
Over here then
Oh, so just back here. Okay. Oh the factory
Production on schedule
This despite the fact that clay Morton Boyer
Spirit of itch and axon rangers were defeated this rage. Smithy will have a new army in no time
A new army you can't be making more weapons. Haven't you caused enough trouble already?
Oh, yeah, who are you that shovel knight?
This is the Mario give up now you still have a chance
It's like a what what like Kirby shovel knight, but like not even meadow knight meta shovel knight
You
Love now you still have a chance
Lowdown shut down production now or he'll stop you
What do you say you'll a puffball mad mallet trash him
You
That's nice
All right, let's see what you got just like just like
All right, never mind. Okay. What do you have now?
Actually, let's get these mad mallet guys out of the way first
Actually now
This attack in they're useless. Oh, that was easy
You
I hope you learned your lesson. We're almost there Mario. Come on
What do you suppose the switch does? Hmm nothing's happening
Oh, what's with the funny face mario? Oh, I know you trying to make me look aren't you? I'm not gonna fall for that one
Ah, kill me mario. Why do you always get yourself in trouble like this?
Boy, that was scary. I guess the green switch controls the crane
What I knew with the crane
Mario
Wait Mario
Give me a second
Oh
I finally made it up here
Let me help you out guys out for princess
I'm sorry. I snuck out without telling you or the chancellor. I just wanted to get back to normal
I want to do my part to help
Princess
Yes, that's it. Any job that lets me help both mario and the princess is worthwhile
Oh, what can you do to help? Well, I carried all I could now. What could you use?
Wait, you still expect me to pay money for this? Oh wait, these are cheap
I
Think I can still do that
Apple cola doesn't really like do much, huh?
Sure
Okay, never mind, uh, I'm I'm set
I'm set. This is for you. Got rock candy. What rock candy in storage box?
Thank you toad. We're almost there. Come on. Let's show them
Here's the report
Third drill bit will be finished on time
We're ahead of schedule
I'll make this smithy proud
Good work, everyone. The work harder we work the stronger smithy will become
Weapons we manufacture here will be just think of it now. This is shovel night middle shovel night another shovel night another metal shovel night
Oh
When smithy takes over mario's world we can do anything we want
Not so fast
The last one was boba fat. That's true
You sure are a cocky bunch. I rule this world. Don't you forget it?
It's mario the clay mornin and speardovitch clones didn't stop him
No, no leave mario out of this. I'm the one you need to worry about not him
Mario you're gonna make you're about to make the longest jump of your life. You're ignoring me
So
Hey
Yay
We're almost there. Um wow
Like the moon over
The day my genius and brawn are lost on these fools
Oh, he's batting his back. Um, well
Oh look they're getting like spray painted here
Another one
You
There are you the one in charge here, do you know what your weapons have been doing to our world stop this nonsense at once
I'm afraid that is impossible any descent against smithy will be dealt with by immediate meltdown
Meltdown you can't scare me. I've got mario by my side
The centers will be eliminated production will continue. All right
Oh the girls pound it
Out
I
My group hug
Oh, yeah, you see that
I
You saw that, right? Oh, yeah. Oh the block. Oh, yeah
Okay
Oh, it's still at its beer, I guess
Oh, even if I block them it still did the thing
Oh, yeah
Oh
Mario should I do physical again, I'll go with physical
Malo
Magic
You know also magic
Oh
That was scary
Oh, we can't run away now. We've got to kick those low lives out of our world
Okay, okay
Yeah
Really
Mario I'm surprised you're here
What's with this ninja? Oh, wait, we match looks up pie. We match look
It's like robo ninja and I have the have like similar fits
I
Want to be a ninja tomb ninjas are cool. I want my ninjas away, man. It's my ninja way. Believe it
This is the end of the line for you this closest you ever get to smithy so save here the moment
have
You'll be fodder to my invincible invention the gun yo
I hate that name
I
Why is it always gotta be stinking eggs?
My timing's so bad can't block
You get this thing out of the way first everybody group hug
Okay, Mario you need a little bit of therapy. Okay, tell me about your feelings
I should have done a group heal. That was my bad
I'm surprised the factory chief didn't go
Hello better for us
Oh
That's unfair look how much left for peach that's so unfair
Hmm the production line hasn't halted look Mario this is where the weapons come from
This must be where smithy makes his weapons
Find the last star piece and stuff the factory you've got to defeat him first
Wow, there's no turning back. Are you ready?
Our quest is almost over
And the time comes
Come on. Let's get this show on the road
It gives me as I go back and uh save
All right final boss time everyone
Should I defeat someone get out of the factory and defeat someone so I can get peaches level up
Me my decisions going
I
Want to get her leveled up
I'm gonna just go get her level up 30 is the cap by the way
Okay, can we actually just jump into one of these guys?
I don't look like it
I can just like get one of him right now. Oh, whatever. Let me get those ninja stuff
Get over here
That's a whole lot of ninjas
Yeah, they just ran away, huh?
Oh
Oh, we're good
I
Okay, yeah, John did it do we have anything
I think we have everything. Yeah
We have everything we need
Well, he stopped ready to rumble
And nothing happened
Oh, oh, oh, I just jumped off. Yay
This is smithy
Hey, there's the last star piece. Oh, yeah, it's on his chest
I
Didn't I didn't know what to say. I didn't think he was actually smithy
You know like a black smith, you know
That was just the dumb name of that big old sword
Huh
Already finished with their tour of the factory, huh? All right, then I'm a little demonstration
You'll smithy stop making those things and hand over the star wait wrong wrong voice. Excuse me. It's for a moment
Stop making those now and hand over the star piece wait stop making those and hand over the star piece now
So you're mario wait so you're mario looks like we're gonna have a little dispute over the star
Just hand it over and get out of my castle
My my we're a little touchy today, aren't we? You know, I'm actually growing a lot of fond of this place
Please please don't make us go through anymore. Just give us a start now
Huh better. Yes. Why don't you give me your stars?
Why then I could easily conquer this world
Then we could get rid of all wishes and create a world filled with weapons
Over here now, I'll crush you all
So does uh does the world thing work on on smithy
Should I kill this mountain first
Okay, the
I'll kill the smother first
Fudge can't walk. Okay, we're doing fine. We're doing fine. I'm doing fine sweetie
Oh
Rainbows
Yeah, I'm gonna get rid of that thing first. What is he making a little guy? Oh, okay, I want to get rid of
I
Are savers
Wait, I can't hit the smothery thing
Oh
Okay, it looks like it's gone it looks like it's it's it's done. Okay die
Hey
Go go go fuck
Um
Fuck again
Oh
I'm a little worried that his HP is gonna be freaking humongous. Uh, can I get Gino in here?
Thanks
Oh
I'm gonna do a therapy for Mario
Does the world work on him
No
Uh, maybe I'll get Bowser out here
I
Not the same just keep hitting just keep hitting everybody's gonna just get some hits. I'll
No
What's going on here
Come now Smithy your hair looks like a geyser
Don't get so worked up think about your blood pressure
We just built this yesterday and we're the and the foundation very weak stop
Stop so stop shaking the floor
Oh, I don't really annoying
Oh, what's up
How in the heck
Are we gonna fight midair now
No
Oh
Burning seething never have it been so wronged. It's a tough. It's a time
I will show you my real form. I will show you my true power. I will teach you respect. I shall have my revenge
You have a true form
Oh
That's ugly. Oh
Come you puny ants you are so much why is there two?
Hold on why is there two?
Should I get the head first or the bottom first I liked him better before
I don't know. I feel like you know, this is such a glow down. He yeah
Well, I'll get the head that oh, wow, I hit the head pretty hard
Wait, he he just turned into a tank. Okay
Maybe I should hit the bottom first
Oh
Fuck
Go can't move. Yeah, that's good
I'll just do a little therapy for myself though
Oh not again
Ah
That was the wrong person I wanted to get therapy too
Oh
Oh ladies back
I'm the girls not gonna lie
It can't block
Whoa, ha ha I'm burning with power
Oh
Okay, hold on
I need more syrup. Fuck it. Let's just get the whole thing
All right
Fuck it
Oh
How many forms is this guy gonna have?
Oh, there's only one we can attack now, okay
Hmm
Nothing
Okay
Do
Super jump
I don't think that's did anything. Fuck it. I don't think that's doing anything. Yeah
Maha, I'm burning with power
Oh
His body is back
Okay
Um
Well, let's see if it's bombs away
Oh, thank you fuck
Oh
Other tank I hate the tank
Fuck
Oh
Can't move hold on
No
I did it I'm blocking
Okay
Can I just use my move now I don't know
The heck is that
Oh, oh triple move, let's go
Oh
Can't move okay cool now we can just hit the
What's that? Oh
Okay, that's fine
No, why that's fine because we have peach
Which
Yes, I poison
Okay, he's getting bombed now I can do this don't worry. I got this I'm pretty sure I got this
Yes
Okay, let's go
Okay
Man
He's just so good at this
Maybe I should switch out to genome sometime soon
Ah
Oh
Here let's see if we can get genome out here
Okay
Okay, royal syrup time
Oh
Can I use this penal flash
It always hurts
Well the same one again
I will hit him with a sign yet again
Okay, can't move
Oh
Okay, what do I do with this one then
I call
Not doing that great
Let's do an attack up
You know
Oh
This guy has so much fucking HP
I still have the item the boost all stats I think so
Yeah, I have a bunch of it
Can I just use the regular genome beam
Okay, Smithy's body can attack again
Let's do the royal syrup again
Get a free heat
Oh, come on
The power of the sun and blindness
He doesn't do any ultimate moves does he
The sun again
Is he gonna change too
Oh
Oh man
Wait, he didn't even was he able to move his his body what the hell
I thought I killed it
I
Die from the power of the sun
Blah
My body and head are burning it's not possible. I don't believe it
No
I'm finished not for you you meddlers
Man you was so tanky
Oh, we did it we got the star the star
Oh
Come on Mario send the last one way up high
Yay
Look it's complete it's a complete we did it we got the stars
Thank you everyone
The star road it's back to normal and
Oh wait, does he have to leave I spent so much time on you
Wait I spent so much time on you
Oh
Oh, is he giving kisses to everyone oh
Don't go emo Pinocchio
Oh
Goodbye emo Pinocchio
Wait that guy's still there wait is his corpse just there wait is his corpse just fucking there
His corpse was there the entire time
Exo's corpse was there just the entire fucking time
You mean we just went into his dead body
Oh, there's the frog
Oh
Playing with mom now
Why is he racing with the Yoshi's oh, it's a cut the cookie. Oh, there's a flower there now
Oh
He made friend with the other guy. Oh wait, they're getting married
They got married oh and the star
Oh
There's the
Johnny yeah, Johnny as like Jonathan right he looks so cool
Yay now he's back to being the prince and he's no longer a frog. How do you lose a son?
Oh
Good
Yay
Oh, they took a picture. Oh, they took a picture
That's so cute. Thank you. Wait, thank you
Super Mario
RPG
Since 1996 based on the original development staff
Oh
Oh, look at that. It's the Lucy be
That's so great
Wait tadpoles can swim on land
Oh
We take our legs now
They're all grown up. That's a big bomb
I
Can drag Bowser's keep yeah Bowser's keep right?
Oh, he's robbing
Oh
I really liked uh Valentina's uh bgm because it was like oh the entire time
I like this guy. I like booster. He's so stupid
You like Mario games are really fun
Uh, the first Mario game that I actually played to completion
I feel is uh really really really kind of dumb is um
A lot of people will probably be like what this is uh mario odyssey. I finished mario odyssey
That was the only one I did and then
Why is that silly because it's one of the later ones right
It's one of the later ones. I did the odyssey. Yeah less
platforming let's let's just say
Way less platforming
I I always thought it's kind of dumb because like people will be like oh that was your first one. It's so
recent
And then after that I uh
Oh like this lineup oh it's 3d now
Uh
After that I uh played
After that I I
Inherited every every system that I got right now. So then I played
Um, what was it then I played
Thousand-year door. I don't think that one had a lot of platforming either
So
And in my past life I played uh
Super star saga
Which I also didn't think don't think it had a lot of platforming either
So
Maybe it's the isometric part that's that's killing me
Oh, there's you know
Ha
It's the bowser and the beach and the malo and the guino
And the fireworks
Oh
That's uh mushroom
Oh, this is great
Bye-bye. Bye-bye, guino
Oh
Ah, that was great that was really great guys
Do I have to hit something
I
Thank you t-bird for the five dollar super chat another game finished. Good job. Call. Hi. Oh, yeah
All right, this is really nice
How many games does this make that means technically three games I finished
Technically three
I
Was starting on scream. Yeah
Thank you. He saw whole daju for the 690 dip
Congrats on another game. Thank you so much. Thank you so much strawberry for the 20 tip as well
Thank you. Oh, yeah
Oh postgame fun will be available. Okay
Clear data it comes with a star
Yeah, okay
Oh
Do you want to play some postgame some pie? I think we still have some time
Thank you so much. Ray kuma for gifting five. Thank you so much
We still have time and I'm still full of energy. I'm super ganky still
I
Oh, you're awake. You look like you were fast asleep. You didn't dream about defeating smithy
Did you what I caught you before you went out to the factory? I got you this present
Gotta stay voucher
Take a night to rest up at the merry more hotel suite before the last push
That's all I had for you. Hope you enjoy your stay in the suite. Wait. I dreamt that
Wait, I dreamt that
Wait, wait, I dreamt that
Wait a second. Yeah, fucking second
No
I
Feel so so lied to should I go to the merry more now?
Let's just go to the merry more
I feel so goddamn lied to right now
Life just isn't fair
I see you have a stay voucher. You're not going to love our hotel's fine suite
The bellhop will show you to your room. Please enjoy your stay
All right
This is the room, please make yourself at home
Feel free to use this terry cloth
Wrote bathrobe after bathing be sure to turn the lights off when you're going to sleep bring that bell for room service
Anything else sir
He wants a tip you give him a cure. Why not?
Thank you very much. Sorry. Please enjoy your stay here. I made infinite money before sure
It's too small for me
I can't even bathe
You sir
At your service sir. How many of you I'm thirsty
Here's the menu
Coca-Cola
One moment, please
Here you are sir out of coca-cola. Oh, thank you
Get out of here
Please enjoy your stay
Hey, is that mario whistling
He's so red now I guess I have to go to sleep, huh
He's so red now, okay, I guess we go to bed
He's so red
What are you doing back?
I
Saw a bright light through the window during the night. I believe it came from star hill
I only go find out what may have caused it
Okay
JK wait, oh it turned
It turned the thing away from me
Oh, how may I help you nothing
I
Is more to me do you know our jack jack period
Good morning. I hope you were able to sleep well. What a disaster
I'm so sorry. I hope it was not my service that got on your nerves
I
Card you have
How about you selling it for me for say a hundred coins is that is that good?
Do not okay
Yes, well then how about five frog coins five that's major
No
What else do you have killing me here, right then ten how about ten frog point coins
Oh
Oh, mr. Wise guy doesn't think ten frog coins is enough. I don't know what you're missing, but oh well
Oh wait
That's that's that's my card. That's my casino card. He wants my casino card. You're right
I'll kill him kill him with hammers
Star hill
Hmm
Come on star hill marry more star hill
Nothing seems to have changed here. Let's keep looking further in
I hope there's still a weak shit weak shot
I
Can't recall the star being here before it must be from where the light came came from
It seems to be a few others perhaps some new wishes have fallen here the frog sage might know more
Can I look at their wishes I hope this is my big break
That's something special to show off
Oh
These ones are new right
I have returned having attained even greater power. I await the one destined to challenge me once again
Wait a second
That one sounds like the guy I just beat
No, he's back. I mentioned for a heated duel
Everyone wants to fight me. No, I don't want to be as a little guy
I wish someone could do something about this cake
I don't saw scratchy make it stop
I
Want our new masters show us his moves
Here's the last one
Oh man, I gotta fight everyone again
Well, there you go
Any new wishes
Oh, these are like old wishes, I'm pretty sure here you go
Oh
He has an itchy throat bull arrow right bull arrow the dog thing that's the one with the itchy throat
Ballero you mean below. Sorry. I I I'm I've got fashion stuck on the head
A ballerow is like an over overcult thing
That's like the looms up to his old tricks again
That's all you have to say
Okay
Well now what
Gotta find him where did you see him last monster town
I did monster town
He was in his room
I
Think we're good
It was here right
This guy again wait this guy again didn't you take the hint after you beat him up twice
Really hope you set out down by now
My throat is scratchy my throat is scratchy is making me all grumpy
He seems really riled up. I think he's scarier than the last time we saw him
Is there any way for one of my minions to talk get it together
You're right. He's tougher than last time but so am I
We've beat him twice and now we can do it again. I'm not letting him push me around
All right
I hope the power of the sun works
Oh
Yeah
Fuck
Oh
Okay, this clone will protect me you look delicious. How about I taste you wow
Act sour
There we are oh is he sour
Oh
Come on
Ah
I
Another clone
Oh, I can't hit him. Oh wait, I can't hit him. Hold on shit. Come on wait help
Thank you never mind
Okay, I gotta use magic I guess
You would never hurt the princess
Oh
You rude rude son of a bitch
Oops, I didn't mean to do that
Okay
Come on, let's group hug this
Maple syrup
Oh, this is hard
Oh
There we go
Wait, it doesn't work on the mawio. I forgot
I
Can't jump on the jump man. I'm foolish
Oh
Wait, I may see hope you're having fun
Just to have your emails do you want me to add them while you're live? Yeah, have them while I'm live. Is that possible?
Oh
I got too excited
I got way too excited
Yeah, I picked out all these and loads myself so I hope everyone likes them
I gave a list and I was like, yeah
Come on maple syrup, let's go
Stop it
Group hug
Let's go
New fireball
Oh
Look you fake Mario
Come on
That was too hard for me right now
Oh
Again come on
Okay, everybody up and at them. No
You got to get rid of peach get out of here. I feel bad hitting peach
That's fine
Oh always resistant
Eating peach
Wait senpai, what do you think do you like him do you like the emotes?
I pick them all myself
Mario is resistant to Mario got it
Oh
This is a hard battle what the hell I thought I was a god turns out I am nothing
I am nothing and I am miserable
I'll please
I
Get you everyone here that I need
Want to switch Mario out here Mario just defend if you
Therapy
You
Can't mute you
There you go
If everyone's ask, okay everyone's happy with the emotes
I saw it's like why why isn't there a this emote that's because I chose these emotes a long time ago
A long time ago. I chose them a long time ago like maybe a month ago
We first started
You
Can't see just what this does
I'm in hell actually
I
When platforming, yeah
How many how does this weird dog have
I
So unfair really
This dog tanky
Keeps on sitting making everyone fall asleep stop doing that
I
First shut the fuck up
I'm so bad at this
I
Be my record
Come on
I
First shut up
Can wake up
Honestly, I'm not having a great time
Why must he have so much in hp
Oh that didn't do much
I
Why is this so freaking tanky
You shut up as well
Okay
I got the wrong item pin time. No, I got got the right item. I'm going crazy now
I'm going crazy now
I
So many hits they don't feel so good
Please die. I'll better no more scratchy throat. I'm for belon to say bye. Bye
I
Feeling when only 31 exp only 31, huh?
Looks like philum spit something out. What is that thing?
Oh the stick might be you want my grandpa's
What how could you tell?
Because he once told me that he lost it around here somewhere
Well, that makes it yours, right? You're the spell slinger of the team. So if anyone can use that thing, it's you
That was brutal
Who suggested I need I do post game
Grandpa, I'll take the stick you left behind and put it to go good use
Now that you finished the game sound player and player report have been added to the journal
Now that you've cleared the game the names of monsters that work question mark question mark question mark in the monster list have been unlocked
There you go
I might get out of here
Never mind get me back in here
There you go
Let me rest here
Uh
Pretty sure this was your idea co-hide. No, it can't be it can't be my idea. No, no
He's not wearing your middle very well and good morning
Now I've become tired
Old and tripled. Thank you for the 199 super chat me sack of ass. Pinky levels went down. I went child went soul down
Ganky depleted ganky is gone. All I have left is
Anxiety to
I
Didn't think it would be this bad co-eye. I'm sorry. Don't hurt me pls zero
Thank you for the late
I didn't even have to read that because text-to-speech work zero
It was the it was the semi colon zero semi colon cry face
I wonder if the expert bomb maker ever stopped making bombs
I
Who is the one that did bombs
Legendary Puccinello. Oh shit. Who is that again?
Thank you, Tygavia. Which of the new amongst your favorite my personal favorite
Is
Hold on. Let me check my list again
Wait that means I have to change my monitor give me a second
I
Gotta pull it up strong you sent it to me recently
Yes, let's see my favorite
Is probably um
the
Is probably that to hit head up
That one's my favorite followed by
I
The really tired looking one
The tired looking one drinking from a mug, which I usually drink my tea from a mug, but you can always interpret it as coffee
And then
Also the the one with the my my face, you know the
You can't see it because it's being covered, but you know the face
There yeah that one
That one you spam it if I do like the focus and then my my my
My mouth turns into like the the the upside down V
Yeah
Yeah, when I'm locked in
Because I notice my face I do that a lot. Yeah, I personally picked all of these ones myself
There's also a sneezing one for any time I sneeze you can just spam the sneeze one and since we've learned a lot and
We learn a lot in this stream
Uh, I also have a sensei emote
Yeah
Actually it uh
It it transfers pretty well like I can see
It pretty well from a distance the sneeze one. I think that's pretty good
I
That was you spitting on us. No, it's supposed to be a sneeze like
It can also be a spit take, you know like what the fuck did he just say?
No, that would be she be you know what I mean
Oh, I should probably move this to the other screen you gotta gotta see it
And then the rest are just kind of like general I feel like would be used quite a bit
I can't remember who's who
I'm miserable though
How many how many of these can I even buy?
Yeah, we have two crying motes now
So one is for tear and the other one is like sobbing
You get what I mean
Ah
Two completely different emotions
Like the first one is kind of like
Um like kind of frustrated maybe a little bit sad
And then just sobbing
It's pretty much I call myself a crybaby all the time because I am
So I have to go back up there. I don't want to do it
I feel like one one post credit thing was enough. I feel like I can't do it anymore, you know
Like my life is just over
I have to do more on this fight
I don't want to do any money fight. I need them already. Why do I have to do them again?
But
I have to go through back through this way I have to go through the whole thing again
It's kind of miserable because these fights are so damn long
So
No recovered fast
Will you play the og final fancies? Maybe
Maybe
I guess if like a lot of supplies are really into it. I've never been like the uh, what do you call?
I've never been the um
Biggest fan of final fantasy. What's going on here?
All right. I owe you for saving my kids
Okay, you want to hear the mobile blues? Well, all right
I get deep in the mines
wait
Don't get much sun
Wait, why is there letters in here?
Why why is there some some letters
Higher oh wait. Oh, I see
The
I'm covered with soil till my work day is done. Okay. I really hate sin. It's labor
I choose because that's the tea time to do them all fill blues
Oh, sorry
Sorry, I missed the dono jo. Yo, stop it. Thank you tiny spiny for the 3 3 3 in case some of you didn't know
Some of mercy's laughs are so high-pitched and they can only be heard by dogs and cats
Mercy is a pet friendly streamer because of this both
For her senpai's as pets and her senpai's
You know, it's so crazy. It's true though. It's true senpai
It's true senpai sometimes my uh laugh gets so high-pitched it doesn't even get caught on the mic
Ow
Where'd he go? Where'd he go? Where'd he run?
Oh, it's blocked now
Oh
Fuck I got stuck well, let's fight
But
Oh, he's back. Oh, it's hell. Oh, I have to go through all of them
Finally showed up ever since you people beat me. I've been refining my technique this time
I'm sure to win fame and fortune here. I come
Muahaha, you think you can beat me and my minions this I'd like to see
Bowser's already famous in his own right. Wouldn't you agree?
You know it. I was known as terror on two legs before you came onto the scene
There you have it fame and fortune are yours assuming you can win shall we find out?
You're the famous Bowser the chain chop and slinging one
That's fine. I didn't bring bombs this time and I'm made in shield to back them up
Good luck finding any holes in this defense much higher level now defeating the famous Bowser and his minion
who catapult me into unprecedented fame and fortune
This is the perfect shield and these incredible bombs can destroy anything the level up me can't lose
Oh
I don't want to do this
How bad is it pretty fucking bad
Oh
Mario's not having a good time
I'm not having a good time
Oh
Yeah on time, baby
Can I do a fireball?
Haven't I figured it out yet?
Got to turn all of them
Oh, yeah, I got to turn all of them then
Fuck
I
Can't tell how I turn them though
Just just hit them hard enough
Why is he hitting so damn hard?
Oh
It's the wrong one
This is miserable
Oh come on
Oh
Why am I timing so so so badly
Bowser out of here
Oh
Come on
There I go
Fuck
Okay, I need the princess to be alive
Oh
And
Yeah, I didn't think it would come to this got no choice to put out all the stops
What the why are you looking me like that?
Bowser's minions are too strong I might be doomed to obscurity after all
Very least let me level up your chain chomp Bowser that way I can remember can be remembered for something
This is the rascally chain chomp, huh? All right, let's level this puppy up
It's gold now all done
That was way easier than everything else and chomp becomes wonder chomp
Oh
Cute what do you think of my new pal?
It suits you the pair of you making it the two of you make an intimidating pair
More haha who dared to mess with the great Bowser in his most powerful chain chomp. No one that's who
Hey, butchinello, you're good at this stuff
I'll do you a special favor and let you put those skills to fixing
To use fixing up my keep
Oh gosh
Yippee with the famous bow wrap sir asking me for my help
Maybe a little thing will rub off on me
My dream has finally come true and now I can show my face around home with pride
We know when repairs when repairs on the keep start now kiom running
Guy sure gets excited easy what's so great about being famous
Who knows who knows but he's giving up on making bombs and that's good enough for me
I
Let me get out of here
I don't want to do this again. I'm gonna go the other way
Why is this one so damn high I haven't figured out how to do this one yet
Oh, I did it
It took me forever, but I did it. Fuck it. Maybe we'll do it this way
I don't want to play this one again this one was kind of annoying
I
Want to play
Oh my motion sickness
Fuck
Oh
Oh fuck
Oh, I'm not feeling so hot
But
Okay, this is better
More coins
Oh
Ah
Uh
When is this over for me I want to I want to I want to leave
Oh
Wait
Yeah
Fuck it. Let's just finish it the smell of money
The smell of money was too strong
Fuck
It's the accelerate
Okay
New record, yay
But take care of the trolley so don't worry about it. Yeah, I didn't think so
Ugh I beat my own time not like it was hard. I just took everything so slowly
Oh
My motion sickness
That's my most jin sickness yawn
Did you quit wonder chop
Not yet
I think booster is looking for some company again Mario booster now that's a guy that's fun
Probably won't be as fun the second time around my god Bellum was so hard
Oh
Boy this fight don't tell me it's it's hard as shit, right?
Okay
It's a what race
I gotta save point don't I?
Where were these numbers when I was fighting bosses, huh? Oh
Yeah, where were these numbers, huh?
I
Still got the eyes
And my eyes are on the prize but also in misery
I
Play now
Um, it's not so bad being stuck in the room. It's not like I get lonely or anything like that
Oh, he gets lonely
Oh
Nice guy the juggling guy I felt it too
Oops
I wonder how mallows attack is now
Why not use multiple save slots in case the main one gets corrupted how's it gonna get corrupted?
This isn't ps2
As far as I know
I
Oh, I found a frog coin I didn't realize no e-wares
Yeah
I didn't feel for a chain chop to attack its own kind. I wonder if it feels any betrayal
You ever think about that senpai
You know, it's just a thought I'm just like wow
I wonder if this chain shop feels anything because like you technically kill them right?
Oh
This is always so cute
The chain chomp violence
Oh special enemies are very weak now nice at least this time
Okay, let's see where's the wife and kids
Wow, wow, it's people did you notice a new addition to my personal railway this one's engine
To zero to three
What you can make that yourself
Hey
What's the skill touch to bill skill touch to build and maintain that all in your own
With all saying words
You know you got there brink lady
This body isn't actually I won't bother getting into it. It's too complicated
Booster do you not remember everything that happened the last time you saw us?
Sure lots of people showed up at my house and then there was a big fuss for some reason now
It's my turn to ask a question. Are you gonna stick around and play with me and my engine 23?
That'll be great fun. Yeah, you bet
Yay, then this train is leaving the station
Oh, wait, I'm gonna start working
Booster seems to be up to something
You can split wait. I thought you said this is like a just train thing
We're here to support boosters so you can make progress on this maintenance
Oh
Right we delay engine zero 23 is now departing
So
What the hell the 99 damage
Even lazy shell couldn't tank that
So
Okay, you still don't do much
Start working
You broke boosters concentration, okay understood I understand the mechanics now
I
Am fucked
I'm fucked. I'm so fucked. I'm so fucked
I
Do
How much do I need to break his concentration?
Just a little bit
So
I
Checking hard
Where's the one that yeah, let's do the Coca-Cola
Oh
Come on
I didn't even get to hit him did I
Did I even get to hit him
He just he just did it
Okay, well, I guess we'll see they seem to have a lot of HP though
So
Wait, can I
Use this
Can I use this against that fucking train?
Yeah
God damn it
So
Seriously just hits them
If I don't kill him he just gets it
So
Immediate moral support
I'm pie thanks jam drops for the
So
How much fucking health do these motherfuckers have
I
Do
Want to leave
I
Can you meet them the mute the mute is uh, isn't it only magic?
I mean put them to sleep. What do we have for sleep?
Where's the try
See by them
So
I
No
No, it's resistant
So
How am I gonna beat them
Now the other one gave morrow support yay
I knew that one was coming I knew that was coming
Oh god peaches like dead dead you can't even select peach
So
Oh
Tactical tactical
Sorry for being so quiet I'm actually like super frustrated
When I'm like super frustrated I just get real quiet
Oh
Shit are you serious?
Are you serious right now? Oh shit. Are you serious?
Oh
One more time
I'm not gonna lie to you that was really brutal
But I don't know if I want to do it again. I'm at that I'm at that point some pie
I'm at that point some pie where I'm just like oh
I already went like what do you call it? I already went nonverbal
I already went nonverbal
Okay, oh god
I was so
I was so close though. You saw that you saw this fight was bullshit. This fight was bullshit, right?
I'm not the only one everyone thinks so
Oh
Everyone saw it and so I'm right
They cheated that's right they cheated not me they did
I
Was like my super baby like no it was it was them all along
From what I've heard booster is the hardest of the pulse game
If I can't imagine how hard this would have been
in
the original
Because I don't think in the original you can switch people out, right?
Or these are new it didn't exist fuck
Oh
There was no post game in the original, huh?
No post game that was it. It's over. Fuck you
Damn they actually made this fight hard hard, you know
I don't even know if I can do like the whole boss rush again. This is awful
This is awful. I'm miserable
And every time I take a long time to beat someone it's like
I don't think I can do it. I'm sorry supplies
I'm sorry some pies
But I am not skilled enough to finish this I don't think I don't think I'm skilled enough to finish this
Not not yet at least I haven't reached the gamer levels yet
So
Give me a second. Let me just
Do
The switch to sleep
That's bullshit absolute bullshit blah blah blah. I hate it. I'm so mad. I'm throwing my mustache away
I
Thank you for the 690 we finished the game any powers call. I don't apologize. I'm I'm just apologizing because
It would have been cool
It would have been cool to end on a win
It would have been cool to end on a win, but I didn't
Mercy modi's waiting you come from oh, you know, I just been around
Ha ha ha ha
Raiden mercy, oh go. Oh my gosh, mercy. Oh might with the mustache
Mercy, I won't be back yet
Ha ha ha ha
Mercy wow you are gone. We got new emotes. Oh fantastic. I love my emotes. I hope you all like them
Oh
Anyways
Anyways, um, what was I gonna say? Uh already for gore
I
Think I think some of the emotes are a little harder to to see when it's so tiny
Uh, but otherwise I think I think I think overall it looks pretty good
They're so much smaller than twitches, uh
There's so much smaller than twitches, um emotes
They're pretty small, but I hope
Even if you even you can kind of like see some details
Some details and be like, oh, I kind of see them. I kind of see them. There's there's a sippy cup one
Oh
And then the drinking tired one
I just started zooming in my browser
I feel the I feel a little sad that some of them don't read that well, but
That's we can blame youtube for that
We can blame youtube for that hardcore
Like the sensei one didn't come out
As well as I expected it, but I hope I hope it's still kind of like
You know, uh-huh, uh-huh
You can use it. I figured the sensei one you can use for both notes and being like, oh, I see and then explaining things
Like taking notes and stuff you can also use it when you learn something something new
So
I think it's very versatile
It's actually but like kind of it's actually but like I don't know cuter
Cuter and I feel like you know
Actually makes you want to just not learn and then this one's just like, you know, like you're in a class
I think that one that one's pretty good
Otherwise I think, um
Yeah, I think that's pretty
That's pretty good. I think most of the emotes are very versatile in emotions
So we can we can have fun with them. Yeah, I chose them out specifically
I have a lot of cry and two drinking emotes because I feel like the two drinking emotes
uh
Kind of show
Kind of show two different drinking feelings like one's like sipping peacefully, you know, maybe like
And then the other ones like I'm so stressed right now
I'm so tired and stressed
And and since
Like regular sippy and hardcore
That's pretty good, I feel like I I chose two drinking ones because
Uh, I feel like senpai's hear me sip a lot
I
So I
I hope that
You know
When you all hear hear me like drink
It's two different types of drinks. Usually it was like casual hi, kate
You and the other ones like let's get this fucking going
Oh
Well, yeah, I have a lot of tears as well because I'm just a cry baby, but each tear represents something else
It's just one is laughing crying kind of like that
Oh
You know though
Tears
And then there's laughing crying
The pouty teary up laughing crying like you're you're laughing so hard your side hurts
And then and then the concentration I can't redo that face unless I'm really concentrating but
It's like that
Walked in face
All right, I think I can recreate it just a bit
There it is
Like that
It's a bit angry it's cuz when you concentrate you look angry all the time when you're focused you look angry all the time
It's like
You know stank face
Stank face when people like are like super concentrated or like they're really grooving to music
Yeah, they're like
Well, they're like having a good time, right?
Me on the other hand, I wasn't having a good time with booster. I love booster, but man that fight was oh shit
Absolutely garbage
Do that again we were like
I
Why you gonna take a screenshot of it
I don't really know what this one is
The horrified face are you are you're horrified you're like
I usually people
I
Actually referenced that card capture soccer a moment
It's kind of like when you're in fear and you hate everything in life. Yeah
Yeah, anyways
It all comes back to kind capture soccer always does
Anyways, this is how I feel after the booster fight
After that booster fight and
The balloon fight this was how I felt the entire time
Like goodbye ganky girl energy it's gone. She's dead. I don't even know her anymore
He had way too much hp though, so yeah
Okay, let's check what my schedule was. Ah, I wanted to end on a win
But we didn't so that sucked, but we beat the game anyway, so
Whatever
Tomorrow is the asmr train
I
Can a few hours
In a few hours you will all get to enjoy six hours of non stop a s m r
I know train mentioned miserable, isn't it?
The asmr will end with me
Start with Icy
Followed by strong
And then I believe it is in May and then she bae and then as
I'll be the caboose of the train
I
Can't I can't everyone has the sound mercy
Icy straw ne
Chip
It may and then as your eyes as your eyes
As
I think oh, wait, wait, wait, we can do like delay
Yeah, yeah, we can do delay as we are delay. You're right. We do the delay
Okay, okay, I say
Johnny
As you are delay
and me
mercy
I think that's the order but it's all day asmr baby choo choo choo
Oh
Wait, wait, yeah design papa's squish
Wow, we're very we're so
We're so there's so much a you know
There's so much
There's so much like wise our eyes there's mommy
Hey
Money
Dear
Hahaha
It's funny that we we keep on getting
We keep on getting like a bunch of a's right
We can fit a until a lot of this
Okay, yeah, but then we have the friday asmr, which is tomorrow
So I'll set that up. Please note that this asmr
Are
Friday
Is tomorrow
It's tomorrow starting in a few hours. So then you will catch
Catch I see I would highly recommend leaving all of us on
For the nice little view for the nice view for the nice for the nice. What do you call it? Uh
You know the algal the algorithm
The algorithm if you get the algorithm then the algorithm can be like the plus one view and then you know, it's better
So we're gonna see
Uh, so yeah, I love all my girls. So starting off with our probably strongest asmr is
Is I see who's who's who's very very very well versed in asmr
Love her to bits
Uh, she's she is she is probably I don't want to say like the best asmr miss asmr
But the most experience the most seasoned a veteran asmr is if you will
And
So I guess we're starting off with the first three's kind of like most familiar and then ending with the uh
With the um
A little bit like the the the three sort of newbies
Well, are you streaming for two hours or one hours? I'm gonna try
To do
Two hours
But since I'm ending it
Maybe it'll give me a little bit of leeway
leeway to end a little earlier
Mostly because
Asmr is hard for me. I I start I start repeating that the the triggers and stuff. I don't even know
You know
I'm confused since she said six hours, but everyone's doing two hours. It would be 12
How long is everyone planning this for?
So
Now I think it's only two hours. Oh wait, I forgot
Oh
I forgot I forgot. I think I think I see is not gonna start it
I think I don't think I see is gonna start it. I think I see is taking the a break right now
I for I forgot I forgot so I would start with scrawny instead later in the day
Oh
That's a shame that's a shame I feel sad. Oh well, I will oh well
It I see I see deserves all the rest she can get in the world
So it's okay. It's okay. She'll probably make up for it. Uh, especially to the snowberries
Or the dad does she'll probably make up for it. So don't worry about it
So so she she's a hard worker. She really is a hard worker. So, uh
Though definitely probably be another one in the future, but but yeah, I'm mistaken. I'm so sorry
I'm so sorry. That would mean that scrawny will start it will start the um ASMR actually is
Looking at the list now a scrawny shibby emmy and then asra and then me
Yeah, we'll channel her energy for our finale
So, yeah wish her all the best all the best I'm sure even
She'll be happy even if the senpai's
Uh wished her wished her luck as well and wished her, uh, good rest
That means no shortening it kohai
I'll try my best then I'm just
I'm pretty new to ASMR's
so
It's gonna be it's gonna be an experience trying to figure out what people like and what people don't like so I'll be testing
I'll be testing a few triggers that I found
And I was like, I think this makes a nice sound probably
I
Apologize, but it might also be very quiet. So I'll try my best to to
Bring up the gain, but there's but I will ask everyone to maybe like
Be very of maybe some soundish some volume issues. Once again, I'm still a newbie
And then
And then yeah, so tomorrow will be mostly me
bearing you all with triggers
um
Hopefully one of them sticks
I'm sure one of them will stick
I'm still very new
And then
The day after since since, uh, the this was the asmr
martrain, uh
The day after the saturday is my
Catgirl ASMR for members only
You must be snippetier or above to go to that
to the
To listen in on that
So it will be shatter day. Yeah such
So I'll I will try my best
I will try my best to give you all a good
scenario real-play scenario
Hopefully it works out, uh, I'll
Really try my best. I'll try my best
To be a good good cat girl
So yeah, those are for my members only I think it will be very special
I think it'll be very special since it's gonna be my first time trying something like that
I
Don't think I ever did like a cat cat thing even in my acting days
I'm thinking about like I don't think I ever got a role
Where it was like had to be like cat like or anything. I remember I had to be a snake once
But I don't think I ever did like
I
About nyan taro nyan taro is not making an appearance here and do cast some Broadway. No
We need to hear some snake mercy. It'll be something like this
That might be a good idea for like a uh
A uh
I think that was the voice I did I think that was really
That was the voice I did when I was a snake
I think that was the voice I did when I was a snake
Nyan taro is not gonna be making an appearance, okay nyan taro knows that it's my time to be the cat
But but nyan taro-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba what about mercy, huh?
What about me? What about my needs?
What my needs, huh?
What about our special date time, huh for every membership, huh?
Remember, every member is a date night in my special time with you.
Only the real supplies are in there.
Or at least, or at least the 1-2 who want the membership are there.
There are other real supplies outside of that, but it's the ones that want the bonus content.
I know some people are just not into membership stuff, so that's valid too.
Because it is like behind a paywall, I consider it a pretty special date, you know?
So I try my best to keep them extra special.
But every time with all my supplies is very special.
I try to make them extra special.
Because I feel like, you know, you've worked very hard, and I was very kind.
And very kind to be supporting, so that's the bonus stuff.
It's mostly me yapping, let's be real, it's mostly me yapping, but...
I think there's like more topics to yapp about.
I don't know, I feel like it's very intimate.
But yeah, I will probably do a public packer ASMR.
It probably won't be the same.
It probably won't be the same experience or scenario, but probably be something else.
Just so the, yeah, just a different tone, and a different theme, or a different type of cat.
So it's not going to be a one-to-one, since I think, I think memberships are extra special,
so I want to make them, I want to make them like different, you know, a bit different.
He's a fairy in disguise, I think I made a fursona a long time ago.
I think, I think it's a great,
I think it's great.
It's like, you know, your pony sonar or something, you just make those shit.
It's a, it's a great way to like, do character creation.
It's just fun.
I won't lie to you though, I do not have like, a fursuit or anything.
What's my fursona's name?
It was Honey.
Like, I don't have,
I don't have like, do I have a special tail though? No, no, I have nothing.
It was literally just, just like a drawing.
It was just a drawing and I was like, oh, it's cute.
It's cute and I was happy with it.
I was cute, I was happy with it.
I'm not very much, I'm not in the, uh, what's the word?
Like, I don't think I would consider myself in the fairy community,
but I would consider myself like, appreciative of the art form.
I hope that makes sense.
Personally, I think I'm more into kimono memes.
Like, personally,
I like, uh, but I wouldn't call myself a part of the fairy community.
I don't feel like I participate too much past having like, this original character.
Past this original character.
I don't know, I think, I don't know, anthral, anthral, promorphic, like, characters are cute.
I don't know, if people are gonna judge me to be like, oh, oh, she, she, she has a fursona,
she's, she's a furry, then, then fucking, fucking, drop, man, man, I can't watch her anymore.
Then I'll just be like, eh, just taking the weed wacker.
I literally, it's like when I was like, oh my gosh, when I was younger.
I was younger, I would make like, self-insert, like, OC's for like, my favorite anime as well.
So I feel like it's not far off from that.
Oh, it's your card capture Sakura OC.
I didn't have one for card capture Sakura, because I just wanted to be Sakura.
It was an OC original character.
It's just an original character in my opinion.
I don't think I've, I don't think I've ever,
yeah, I don't have like a fursuit or I don't have like anything, like,
I don't have much art of my quote unquote fursona.
Actually it more, it feels more like an original character, the more I think about it.
I'm like, actually that's probably more like a original character that happens to be
furry and anthropomorphic.
The more I think about it, I'm like, actually, it's more like, you know,
it's more like an OC, but I call it a fursona.
What's the distinction?
I don't know.
That's why I'm like thinking about like, fursona is like your embodiment, right?
Like an embodiment of like a representation of you, right?
But then I'm just like, wait, this means that this character is more like
just my original character, right?
Yeah, oh well.
There's, there's a lot of layers to this.
Now that I think about it, it's more like maybe a,
maybe it's more like an original character than a fursona.
It's just an original character that happens to be a furry.
It's just a lot.
Okay, I'll have to talk to like, I'd have to actually talk to like
someone in the furry community in order to, to, to get it, get the specific nuances.
Because I remember there were some people that said, you know, even if it's not like a
character that's supposed to be them, but they also called it a fursona as well.
But then I'm just like thinking back and I'm like, ah.
I don't know.
There's many layers.
I, there's many layers.
I did some research and I also made some friends in the community
and they were very kind.
They were very kind.
They do a lot of charity work, actually.
They do a lot of charity work, which is, which is why I kind of
got interested in it in the first place.
Got a Muppetsona and a Parashibi?
No, I don't have a Muppetsona.
I can't remember if I did volunteering or something.
But I don't have a Muppetsona yet.
Yet, um, yeah, I have like, I made like old sees and stuff.
I feel like my, I love, I love being creative, you know?
I love being creative.
So another, one way of being creative is through me is designing
and character world building, et cetera.
Honestly, if I really like doing that, like world building and stuff, lower building.
Like the fashion design for gen mates.
Yeah, I had a lot of fun with that.
I had a lot of fun with that.
Um, the girls seem to really like it too, so I'm happy.
I'm happy.
I thought they would be like, oh, it's all right.
But like, some of them were like, oh, I really love that.
I hope I get an outfit like based off of it.
And I'm like, yeah, yeah, you have my full permission to use it.
If you are sure.
Making some sort of, you know, um,
making some sort of like, something inspired by it.
It's even fine too.
Maybe another stream designing some other outfits.
I would have to, I have to learn how to use Krita.
I have to relearn how to use Krita because it's been a while.
When I say like, I'm a pretty fashionable girl.
I'm a pretty fashionable girl.
I know way too much about fashion than I would like to admit.
Despite that, it's like, yeah, I know a lot about fashion.
What's my wardrobe t-shirt?
T-shirt.
Oversight.
All of them are oversized t-shirts.
T-shirts.
Hand me downs.
Really ugly dresses.
Paisley, exactly.
Paisley dress.
Buddies.
I think, I think it's just because I'm like more self-conscious about myself with fashion.
Or maybe less self-conscious about myself and fashion.
When I think of them, like sometimes I go out in the really ugliest dress ever and then I don't care.
Like it could be just that.
I'm just thinking about it, but I know quite a bit about fashion.
I used to like dress up to the nines all the time.
And now I'm too tired and too much of a neat to do that.
Well, I guess I'm no longer a neat.
I guess I'm not really a neat anymore.
Not a neat girl failure.
Okay, okay.
Let's not go too far.
Let's not go that far yet.
I don't think I'm a girl failure.
Maybe I'm a girl loser.
Maybe not a girl failure.
Like a girl loser, not really a winner.
Girl you go on hikes and legs and spice social media.
Yeah, recently.
Speaking of going outside, I was swimming.
It was really fun.
My friend, the gal pal, the gal pal, by the way, is the gal pal.
That is super, super biased who gave me all the stuff.
We went out and we went to one lake.
Oh, the console girl, yeah.
We went to one lake and it was really busy.
But she had her dog with her.
She had her dog with her.
And I was like, we looked at the lake and we're like,
there's no signs saying there are no dogs allowed.
But we don't see any dogs at all, right?
So called the park management.
Let's just say that.
I think they're kind of like a park management.
Called them, turns out dogs not allowed.
Dogs can be on the grass, not in the water.
But it's a hot day, so we want the dog in the water, right?
It's a hot day.
The dog should be in the water playing around in the water, right?
So I had to drive a little bit further to a different lake.
Wait, is this the dog that bit you?
Yeah, the dog that bit me.
She's a good girl.
Just kind of dumb.
Grand better.
It still hurts a little bit, but overalls.
It's okay.
She's kind of stupid.
So went to a different lake.
Lots of dogs.
They're having fun.
I can go in the water as well with the dog.
He's having a blast.
Kids are playing with Paris at her up.
And you know, she's really active, right?
Is the dog okay after biting my hand?
Why wouldn't the dog be okay?
She just went off and play.
She didn't even realize she bit me.
And I was holding a stick up for her.
And I'm holding the stick.
You know, like how you kind of hold like a, I don't know,
like a light stick, like at the end, right?
I was holding it at the end for her to bite the stick.
This whole fucking area of her to bite it.
And then she fights my hand and I'm like,
I'm like, yelp.
And then just like pulled away.
That was it.
That was nothing.
Yeah.
I have this whole area where she can go,
where she can just bite.
And then she just bit my hand instead.
I was like, oh my God.
She's sweet though.
She's sweet.
A good doggy.
A little dumb though.
I thought that was a little, little dumb of her, but she didn't even notice.
She just went.
She's a rescue dog, so I can't go too hard on her.
I can't go too hard on her.
She didn't.
She didn't mean any harm.
She was just playing, so it's fine.
So it's just fine.
I got tiny, tiny, tiny little cuts.
Like itty bitty, itty bitty.
Like I got pricked or like, and when you get a paper cut or something.
Teeniest, tiniest.
But it hurts.
It hurts.
And it didn't draw blood until I was out of the water, of course.
And then, and then I had like a first aid kit, so I just put band-aids on the first, around it.
And then I got home and then sanitized and washed my hands, etc.
So yeah, it wasn't, it wasn't a big deal.
It wasn't a big deal.
Like I would be more worried if like she like chomped down, but like she just went.
Trying to grab the stick.
I was like, there's that whole area of stick.
Why did you bite my hand?
It's fine, it hurts, it hurt at the time.
And then it hurt even more because I guess the pain started to settle down and I was like,
so it's always the littlest cuts or littlest anything that hurts the most.
It's the littlest cuts that hurt the most, I find.
I remember like cutting like a big, big like cut and I just like look at it and I'm horrified
seeing a big cut.
And then, but like it doesn't hurt much.
But then, you know, like a paper cut, you're like, my life is over.
Guess the adrenaline hits in when it's a bigger cut, but like it doesn't hit when,
when you have like the tiniest thing.
I'm tiniest cut.
So that's why it hurt extra.
I guess.
See your friend for more consoles?
Absolutely not.
I love her the bits.
Actually, I was that time after the lake, I was like, oh my gosh, I'm having so much fun.
And she was like, oh my gosh, we should do a sleepover like now.
And I said, yes.
And then I realized I didn't bring a spare change of clothes.
So then we're doing a sleepover again.
Sunday instead.
We're doing a sleepover again on Sunday.
It's going to be like a movie night probably.
Oh, she took a picture of the dog when it got home.
And she like immediately went to her dog bed and she and she looked so pleased.
So I was really happy.
Are you here?
Some of you are going to movie nights movies.
Actually, I wouldn't call them movie nights since they're more like TV shows.
Sometimes we do the dumbest thing.
This is, I would call it the dumbest thing.
The most brain dead thing you can do is that we just put on like really old like cartoon chills.
Like I think we put on the backyard again.
We put on Nanalan.
We put on recess.
Somehow we ended up watching recess two times in a row.
You know, like those types.
Is backyard against really old?
I think it's pretty old.
Oh, it's backyard against.
Oh, it started in 2004.
Yeah.
Everyone's sun leash fiddles up.
I think I also watched like a bunch of...
Oh yeah, like watching Arthur as well.
You know, just watching like cartoons.
You know, thinking about it now.
Like I remember looking at recess and I'm like, I totally did not.
I totally did not.
I totally did not get any of these jokes when I was younger.
Like sometimes like, that flew over my head.
A lot of recess.
I was like, wait, that totally flew over my head.
So yeah, I was like, oh.
Sometimes I'm just like really surprised about some of the jokes and recess.
Like what the teachers talk about.
I'm like, that's pretty grim.
But yeah, I'm just like, oh, you know, just rewatching things.
I think I even watched...
Oh shoot, I gotta Google this one just to make sure it's not like a local thing.
Okay, it's not local, but it's not local, but it's Canadian.
It's not global, that's for sure.
It's Canadian.
It might out me.
No, it won't out me.
It won't out me at all.
Okay, it was called Dudley the Dragon.
It might, it says here, it's like shown in the U.S. a bit too.
It's called Dudley the Dragon.
Watched a bit of that.
Oh, watched Mona the Vampire, those type of stuff.
It's, I don't know, I really liked, I really liked like children's media.
So yeah, I think one media that people don't remember.
Canadian, Canadian media that people don't remember, but I do is...
Okay, it's called, god damn it, when was it released?
Okay, I don't think, I don't think it's gonna like,
I think it was ongoing for a while too.
Anyways, it was called Yvonne of the Yukon.
I bet if I watched that again, I would be like, oh my gosh, there's so many jokes now.
I remember watching this and I had a great time watching it.
I had a great, great time watching it.
Isn't Canada, there's some media about, maybe it used to be 50% French?
No, it should be 50% Canadian.
Not just French, I think in...
I think in, in Quebec though, like, everything must be 50% French and English,
but the main language should be French.
I think, I can't quite remember.
But let's be real though, actually most media that came, like media that I watched,
also came from Quebec, so, you know.
So yeah, I ended up having, liking a lot, actually the cartoons, there were so many
cartoons and I think I just enjoyed all of them.
I just enjoyed a lot of cartoons when I, when I was younger.
I watched a lot of experimental ones too.
Some of them might be even like, lost media now.
Some things might be like lost media now, because sometimes I try to remember
a show, I remember it quite vividly and then I can't find it.
And I'm like, oh, it's gone.
It's gone forever!
But I think there, there was quite a robust amount of cartoons.
I'm so yapping, holy shit.
It's okay.
How long did I yapp for?
Tired.
At least an hour.
An hour?
A little over an hour?
About an hour mostly?
Like an hour.
I feel like you're all lying to me.
I feel like it's been over an hour.
Anyways, I have some chores to do tomorrow.
I have some choice to do tomorrow and
and I gotta get ready for the ASMR stream.
For the ASMR stream, I'd like to reiterate that I may not be able to interact as much maybe,
or I might take, might or might not take requests depending on which.
So yeah, that's about it for today.
I can't think of anything else.
I was yapping for a long time.
I'm pretty sure I'm yapping for a long time.
Anyways, I do have choice, so I gotta go.
So anything else to cover?
No?
Oh yeah.
Use code mercy at GamerSup for 10% off your order.
Your order.
Also, also, also.
I feel like you all should comment more.
I feel like you all should comment more on the VODs.
Yeah, like on the VODs.
Like, comment, subscribe on YouTube.
And as well, oh shoot, I should have said this at the beginning of the stream.
But if you guys ever find something or you remember a part you liked in the stream,
please clip it.
I would highly recommend it because it helps me choose what parts are good to make into shorts.
And so please just clip it.
Just clip the part using the YouTube Clipper.
Cool?
And that's about it, I think.
Yeah, just like clip, just do the regular clipping.
Like how you would on Twitch.
I would like to remember some of the parts that were cool as well.
YouTube has a clip tool?
Yeah, it does.
It's new.
And so I'll take those parts and then I'll send them off to scrawny who will send them off to
an editor and then should we share the clip too?
Oh, you don't have to share it, only if you want to.
Only if you want to, only if you want to.
But I always go back and check them every once in a while and see what parts you guys like best.
And maybe it'll be a video and maybe it could be our little ha ha inside joke together.
I'm not going to force your hand, but I would appreciate it.
I really appreciate everyone who who clips because it makes making shorts and
seeing the fun times way easier.
It makes it way way way easier.
I always should say that, but I just remember
I always remember that I should probably say it.
Yeah, so thank you so much for joining me today.
I'm a yeet.
I don't think anyone's on.
So I'll see you all again next time.
Bye bye.
Stream for Mercy.